it's the first election in punjab since
farmers led year-long demonstrations
against legislation they feared would
leave them at the mercy of large
corporations
the welfare of farmers is always a big
issue in the state known as india's
breadbasket but is just one of many
facing voters
inflation has hit us hard
prices of cooking gas and food grains
have been rising for some time our
earning isn't enough
what can a family that earns only one
hundred dollars a month spend on
we want the next government to ensure
better education for all our studies
have suffered for the past two years and
we expect the next government to ensure
our studies don't suffer anymore
despite forcing the government to
withdraw its controversial changes to
agriculture laws farmers leaders say
they haven't been able to raise other
serious challenges facing the state
[Music]
the crisis in the agrarian sector along
with the issues of ecology environment
depleting water table and hell have all
gone missing in this election no one
raised these issues and the unity of
farmers wasn't strong enough to make it
happen
political analysts say that might
benefit prime minister narendra modi's
hindu nationalist bharatiya janta party
the bjp is campaigning on security
issues in the state which borders
pakistan
that that card of border street
card of drones
caught a card of insecurity for a
particular community
has played a role and in the last 10
days
they have been able to accumulate and
gather
a particular community votes for sure
hindu community
[Music]
the battle in punjab is between the
incumbent congress party a regional
organization called shiromaniyakali dal
which might partner with the bjp and aam
aadmi or common man party if india's
main opposition party the congress lose
power here in punjab it would be a
devastating blow for india's oldest
political party it only holds power in
three of the country's 28 states
india's largest state uttar pradesh is
also holding elections staying in power
there would give the bjp a major boost
in its bid for a third successive
victory in the next national election in
2024
defeat in uttar pradesh or in any of the
other three states which also vote this
month would increase pressure on the bjp
its leaders are already facing criticism
for high unemployment and their response
to the covet 19 pandemic elizabeth
paranam al jazeera patiala punjab